who would have guessed who would have
guessed that
if you get vaccinated you're very
unlikely to catch the coronavirus
because the vaccines are so effective
but that if you're unvaccinated
especially if there's lots of
unvaccinated people around you
and you're around them indoors without
masks
for extended periods of time you are
more likely to get sick if a more
transmissible variant comes forward
and that is exactly what is going on
right now
a new washington post report coronavirus
infections dropping
where people are vaccinated rising where
they are not
and the article goes into detail to tell
us something that
i mean it who would this be a shock to
right
states with higher vaccination rates now
have markedly fewer coronavirus cases
makes sense as infections are dropping
in places where most residents have been
immunized
and are rising in many places where
people have not a washington post
analysis has found
states with lower vaccination also have
significantly higher hospitalization
rates
poorly vaccinated communities have not
been reporting catastrophic conditions
instead they're usually seeing new
infections holding steady
or increasing without overwhelming local
hospitals
as recently as 10 days ago vaccination
rates did not predict a difference in
covet cases
but immunization rates have diverged and
case counts in highly vaccinated states
are dropping quickly
vaccination is not even within each
state the post found the connection
between vaccine shots and covet cases
at the local level comparing more than
100 counties with low vaccination
meaning under
20 vaccinated and more than 700 counties
with
high vaccination meaning at least 40
percent vaccinated
and here is the here are the findings
and we're displaying them graphically
for you
counties with high vaccination have low
covet rates that are going down
in counties where few people are
vaccinated not only are there higher
case rates but the number of cases is
also growing
this is in the absolute this is really
important to understand
if you look at places with fewer
vaccinations and more cases and you see
cases above the national average these
are places like
wyoming idaho alabama louisiana arkansas
west virginia
indiana missouri what do these places
have in common i think you understand
politically what's going on there
you then look at the lower right
quadrant on this graph that we're
showing our audience
the places with more vaccinations have
fewer cases
places like vermont massachusetts hawaii
connecticut new jersey rhode island new
hampshire pennsylvania california
maryland
dc what do these places have in common
well politically they're very blue
now there are a few outliers there are
some places with more vaccinations
and also more cases uh the there's
really
four states in that quadrant colorado
oregon washington and maine
we're still trying to figure out why
that is
and uh we we we don't we don't yet know
um so the takeaway here of course is
go and get yourself vaccinated it's it's
really that simple
if you want to protect yourself and
others go and get yourself
vaccinated and you know the the doom and
gloom
uh is correct in unvaccinated
communities
a 60 more transmissible variant which is
what we believe the delta
indian variant uh to be at this point in
time
is going to burn its way through a
population
as it finds people who are not
vaccinated when you are vaccinated
because the vaccines are so effective
not only is it less likely i mean
how are we even saying this now in june
of 2021
you are less likely to get sick and
people around you are less likely to get
sick because the vaccine
does not guarantee immunity it is not
100 effective
we all do something for our community
when we get ourselves vaccinated so
shocking right who could have seen it
coming
that the places that are more vaccinated
are doing better
than the places that are not now as more
international travel resumes
spain hazar is about to open italy has
or is about to open france has opened
to vaccinated people etc will vaccinated
travel
to countries that are not yet as
vaccinated as the united states
will that increase rates i believe that
it will not
because vaccination is mostly happening
fast enough in
the majority of those countries uh that
things are going to remain
under control nothing that's happening
is surprising
and i see people you know people on the
left and on the right posting
things to to twitter and to facebook etc
as if
anything other than what we're seeing
was predictable the place is getting
vaccinated quickly particularly when you
get to 50
cases drop like a lead balloon a places
that are not are going to continue
getting sick particularly as these
variants spread
no no surprise just simply no surprise
tell me what you're seeing
in your neck of the woods you can find
me on twitter at d pakman
we have a huge show for you today